President Trump who just tweeted shut
down coming question mark says he's
trying to avoid a shutdown but he says
Democrats quote want to see one the
president spoke in a western
Pennsylvania factory after one of his
tweets threatened his party's
negotiations to keep the government
running major Garrett traveled with the
president last night and is with us now
major
good morning good morning let's be
honest the government shutdown on the
one-year anniversary of President trumps
ignore ation not exactly an
advertisement for high functioning
Republican control of Washington so the
White House and Republicans on Capitol
Hill need to stick together and blame
Democrats for this particular impasse
the president's Twitter habits well
yesterday that made it a bit of a
challenge see what happens inside a
Pennsylvania equipment factory Thursday
roughly 250 miles away from the shutdown
drama president Trump attacked Democrats
for obstruction I really believe the
Democrats want to shut down to get off
the subject of the tax cuts because they
worked so well hours earlier Twitter
comments from the self-described a
dealmaker threatened to throw
negotiations into a tailspin mr. Trump
argued an extension of the children's
health insurance program known as chip
would only be part of a long-term
solution
House Republicans ignored that take and
included the program in their short term
bill the President's budget priorities
are heavily focused on defense spending
and border security both appealing to
his base supporters
the White House insisted that John to
the Keystone State was not a campaign
stop but it sure felt like one a real
friend and a spectacular man Rick
Ciccone just over a month after an
embarrassing party defeat in Alabama
Senate race mr. Trump endorsed the
Republican candidate in a special house
election however he could not resist a
trump esque jab at the scene unfolding
on Capitol Hill easy it's nasty in
Washington but step-by-step-by-step just
keep going right go and stay it is a
nasty place woo oh the president is
discovering the hard bargains that must
come with bipartisanship in these
polarized times he's not the first
president to learn that lesson but mr.
Trump promised he alone could cut the
biggest and best deals and with time
running out the president will need a
better strategy then we'll see what
happens all right major thank you